it's like I got the rebound I'm coming
down elbows out and my sense that you're
gonna try to steal it I'm gonna elbow
you in the face make it look like a like
I missed like a joke or like I did it by
mistake hit my outlet of course so the
moral is hey
like little guard guy like it's my
rebound get away from me so I think
there's something to that like Darth
Vader
he's like the ultimate like hey little
guard like get off everybody else's a
little guard to him he should win look
at that guy he's the baddest dude in the
universe like he should win I like
dynasties I like dominant teams
I like the bad guy I believe that each
and every one of us has the power within
ourselves to create the life that we
really want and I want to help give you
the tools to make that happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
I'm giggling as I introduce this next
guest because his name is challenging
but I think after many versions of
potentials and then him clarifying it
here I go
Joe Manganiello you'd know him from
movies like Magic Mike
or the show True Blood being married to
Sofia Vergara tall handsome man that is
also interested in Dungeons and Dragons
that's right you heard me right
he also has a clothing line called death
saves which will explain about how he
called it death saves which means
nothing to me but it's perfectly
understandable if you play D&D Dungeons
& Dragons we also talked about his love
for sports as he had these sort of
dichotomy of a life of beingness as he
would say you know nerdy guy playing D&D
and then of course this other side
because he's six foot five and very
athletic how he could be you know
captain the football team the basketball
team and he I think there was one other
sport who's I lose track of how many
captains he was because he was so
athletic
and it still is so we touch on that at
the very end with him being into
CrossFit which you know when someone's
into CrossFit because they'll tell you
and that's me so we talked about that
but we just talked about we talked about
a lot of really random things and when
we got into aliens we got into
meditation he does and I won't get this
right word right either Transcendental
Meditation fascinating guy it was a
really really fun conversation and I
hope that you you enjoyed it as much as
I did doing it so thank you for
listening today
[Music]
obviously like probably the most
surprising thing and reading more about
you is that of course you grew up
playing Dungeons & Dragons which I
actually don't even know what it is so
maybe you could explain what it is I
don't know if it's a game is this a role
play is this a Nintendo game is this a
board game is this characters you hold
in your hand I don't get it
everything you just said oh my god since
so yeah you just kind of nailed it like
if some of you asked somebody and they
just said what you said that would be it
so before video games yeah I mean you've
played some video games I mean I
remember playing duck hunt and you know
track-and-field on Nintendo okay you
were play like Super Mario Kart okay you
were play like I don't know any of the
adventure games like a Batman game
Fred's dead redemption anything like
that no there was one game though it was
on the computer and you had a gun and
you were like the gun holder and you
walked around and shot things and I
remember playing that one time that was
kind of a little bit fun but that's
literally the extent of my well that
game wouldn't exist if it wasn't for
this game hmm
so this game came out before that there
was technology to you know hold a
controller use something on a screen but
all the algorithms all the programming
was taken from Dungeons and Dragons
Dungeons & Dragons figured out how to
make you a first-person individual
inside of another world which then
became video games the idea of like
leveling up or gaining a level that all
came from this game they figured out how
to do it with dice and probabilities and
paper and then that became kind of the
basis for what video games were built
upon now recently there's been a real
resurgence of the game I think in a
retaliation against being on your phone
all day yeah on the phone all day so
what are you gonna do you're an isolate
you bet on your phone all day the kids
don't even call each other they just
text you're gonna put it down then
you're gonna go into a room by yourself
and then play this game by yourself so
what a lot of people are doing
especially you know my generation I've
you know we used to have poker night
you know guys get together play poker
smoke cigars we now
instead of Poker played D&D which is
what we're doing we're kids and that
we're all in LA working in entertainment
as professionals but we all kind of
scratch that itch as kids growing up
playing this game
and so as adults it's kind of a it's
like a whole different how what was the
original form of let's just call it D&D
it sounds cool
our dungeons and dragon tensions and
Dragons it's fantasy oriented in that
world that way but so dandy what was the
original way played it well so
originally it was it was wargaming so
givers like there are people that go out
and reenact oh yeah yeah sure yeah
there's like renaissance festivals for
like reenactments of eras famous battles
so like like like my uncle used to go
out he lived in he was like a Minuteman
in Massachusetts and he would go out and
they would reenact these famous
Revolutionary War battles okay ya know
and they would figure out here died how
many people there was down so it was
like a science and they had the muskets
and they would fire him and you go down
then you go down and they would replay
these battles so you could kind of get
an idea of what it was like inside of
that so that then there were these guys
who there was a tradition of wargaming
where they would figure out how you had
these miniature figures it eats people
in the basement painting and they would
reenact the bowels versus each other and
see if you know you could change the
outcome of the Battle of Waterloo or you
could change the outcome of Custer's
last stand could Custer could you win
with what Custer was given and then it
goes back to like even like battles of
Alexander and Caesar so they would play
these battles out and in the 1970s this
guy named Gary Gygax said well what if
rather than controlling an army you were
just one soldier and what if you can't
come up with the name of that soldier
and what if you could come up with all
the statistics of that soldier and what
if you could fight as that soldier and
then a step further what if we didn't
just reenact battles what if what if
like you went in a dungeon and fought a
dragon or something and his partner said
that's stupid let's just stick to these
war games and Gary split and he started
this game that then caught on and really
became for me as a kid it was like if
you watched Game of Thrones
mm-hmm it's that's like D&D or Lord of
the Rings it's you know you're watching
a long-form storyline unfold episode by
episode and that's kind of like that's
just what it is so it was for me it was
the basis for learning how to build a
character I mean I build a backstory I
also used to run those games so it was
like I became a writer that way
I started thinking ahead in terms of
episodes and how to develop characters
over those episodes which then became
the skills and tools that I used on you
know five years of True Blood which was
a fantasy show yes so all of all of
these things I've done in my career
there were the kind of the The
Fountainhead of creativity came out of
this game and there are a ton of people
in town who work in film and television
who also did the same thing coming out
of the party yeah I mean like my home
game is like it's insane it's like I
mean I was joking today that like we
could probably put it on NBC and get
good numbers like there are like the
amount of like the talent that's in that
room that plays it's crazy it totally
goes to support my theory that you can
make a job out of anything
I write for Dungeons & Dragons now I am
on payroll
I make figurines I write storylines I
create characters it's the job of one it
is you manifested your childhood dreams
it's over right that's it as you're
gonna just done all the more efforts on
it I'm just gettin started well no I
mean but i-i've always said that it's
like well you know I'm in a movie with
Arnold Schwarzenegger and I'm like how
is this possible then he's writing the
foreword to my book and I'm like how is
this happening and then Paul Reubens
calls me and says I want you to be
pee-wee Herman's best friend it's just
it goes on and on it's like I don't like
God I'm tried I stopped trying to figure
it out a long time ago well you seemed
kind of taken aback by it so then what
was your childhood like me watching all
of those people and I just mentioned I
was a I was taller than everybody
growing up in athletic so I was the
captain of whatever team from the time I
started still taller than everyone just
my kid brother six-foot-seven how are
you six-five terrible for you I bump
into Shaq at the Netflix office last
week a little taller well tell them yeah
so it's like you go to the gym you look
to your left there's a bunch of people
smaller than you look to your right so
much people bigger than you absolutely
you know just life that's the wall next
to you by the way that wasn't actually
people that's the only thing $2 so you
you played these games you loved it like
what was to do I mean was it an escape
were you ever trying to escape from
something cuz they feel like that you
know they but I mean fantasies not out
of the realm of being a child but was
there what was the driving force why you
really like dove into it and loved it
yeah I think definitely the getting off
the planet aspect I'm on the board at
Pittsburgh Children's Hospital and I
went back and started the Dungeons &
Dragons Club there for the kids so
during their IV time which sometimes
takes an hour and a half two hours stuck
to an IV right and these are kids like
one of the kids had a double lung
transplant he was on oxygen
oh my god you know there's just wires
and cables you know and just IV lines
going everywhere and you know you
generally try to protect kids from
having to grow up you want them to stay
kids you want them to stay protected and
when kids get sick like that you can't
so you know this game you know whether
it's a book or a video game or or
Dungeons & Dragons you it provides an
escape for someone where they can get
out of their own life and go be you know
entertained you know I think that's why
a lot of people go to the movies or get
sucked into movies or while it's such a
romanticism about going to the movies
because you can get out of your shitty
life fiction novels whatever like social
media a magazine or you know what is it
the Fifty Shades of Grey sure sure wait
that's a reality
some people you know so so you got me to
the hospital and show these kids how to
play how many characters the basic
mechanics of the game they must go away
so they were yelling jamming and
high-fiving and I want to go kill that
Goblin and you know and and and they you
could tell that they they weren't
thinking about any of this yeah going on
around them they were just they got to
be somebody else and take a break
yeah from who they were and I was trying
to teach them that that there's a way
out of that yeah and some of the kids I
just got an email from one of the kids
and he got home yeah and Todd his
brother had a play and while they play
in the neighborhood oh my god so that's
that's gonna be like those are the
stories that must like I'd be bigger
than nearly anything where you realize
you've just changed a life he's given
them something to be joyful about yeah
yeah but there's there's really
something I think to the game that like
I said it was like it was just this
engine for me to and be endlessly
creative yeah for my for the rest of my
life so why do you cheer for the bad
guys then that's a good question it
sound so positive until you cheer for
the bad guys like Darth Vader if you're
gonna say something like the Pittsburgh
Steelers know oh yeah like history
skills that would be another bad guy ya
know we I don't know I guess I growing
up i I liked being afraid I liked I
liked the lights off I liked I liked the
idea that there might be monsters in the
closet like I like that and I want to do
become friends with them so that we
could you know like III never I always I
rooted for Vader I thought why shouldn't
this guy win you know I I'm ever getting
in trouble for written for like jaws I
don't know what was wrong with me I read
for Godzilla I always you said you like
deep diving and thinking so can you
please explain to me how that like there
must be some psyche to that that's like
oh that was part of my childhood that I
shoved down deep I don't know if it's
that or if it's like I was I was the
center on the basketball team and when
you fight to get a rebound and you bring
the ball down and some like little guard
slaps it out of your hand
and it's like there's nothing worse than
that feeling like you just want to kill
everybody in the arena when that happens
so you know I think it goes back to that
it's like it's like I got the rebound
I'm coming down elbows out and my sense
that you're gonna try to steal it I have
an elbow you in the face make it look
like a like I'm like a joke or like I
did it by mistake hit my outlet of
course so it's like oh the moral is hey
like little guard guy like it's my
rebound get away from me
so I think there's something to that
like Darth Vader he's like the ultimate
like hey little guard like get off
everybody else's a little guard to him
he should win look at that guy he's the
baddest dude in the universe like he
should win
I like dynasties I like dominant teams I
like the bad guy
and Satan apparently no this is this is
an evangelical Christian theme yeah
let's see it cuz you have a clothing
line called death saves which is right
if you have a straight line you okay or
something
Shane would want me to tell you to do
something different but I'm just gonna
have you read what's on your shirt kids
in satanic oh I didn't that that didn't
realize I said satanic RPG horror you're
just throwing Satan I mean I did yeah my
subliminal advertising I guess like you
know he's winning right now on some
level in the world
I mean well I don't I don't know
anything about that all I know is that
this is an actual Daily Mail front page
is it really yes are you talking about
the clothing line how you decide what
goes on it and what like first off why
did you start what is no no let's back
up further hmm what does death saves
mean well it means a few things I guess
I think sent me to you there's a bit of
it that the world there there is and
there is an ode to old-school gaming in
that so it's kind of you know you could
someone who is a gamer would see that
and instantly recognize that term but
it's subversive in that I mean in the
game when you're when you when your
character gets like you know when
somebody knocks you down the zero hit
points
you know all of your your energy you've
been you've been okay you know and your
once you read zero hit points you'd go
into a series of roles let's see if you
live or die okay and that's what that's
a reference to number one number two I
mean there is a bit of a tipping of the
cap or in hopes of catharsis for the
kids out there who I knew many of them
whose parents and churches took their
Dungeons and Dragons books burnt them
took their Stephen King books and burnt
them took anything that had to do with
magic or the occult or fantasy or Ozzy
Osbourne or Black Sabbath and went and
burned it and said that you know Satan
was reaching out when if you listened to
Aussies lyrics Ozzy's talking about
running away from the devil he's talking
about not giving into it these games had
nothing to do with anything revolving
around Satan there were fear what they
don't understand and in religion you're
in a small little box yeah there was a
really shameful sixty minutes interview
of that Bradley back in the 80s where he
coerced parents into admitting that
their children killed themselves and
killed other people because of Dungeons
and Dragons there was never an apology
that you know this wasn't true obviously
insane I mean the West I mean we I play
with some of the biggest celebrities you
know my house in my home game disclose
their names no they're fine right you
know but like the West Memphis Three
they were they were put in a prison for
murders that like if you look at the
evidence clearly they did not commit
these murders but because they wore all
black and they listened to Metallica
they were put in jail as scapegoats for
someone in the neighborhood who was
murdering children so you know I don't
what do I think that's about I don't
know someone's excuse for bad parenting
so they're gonna try to figure out some
way something to blame mm-hmm well we
project you know what we're insecure
about so so this is like this is
actually an anti Satan front page of an
old newspaper that I am now it's wearing
ironically very appropriate I think
perhaps it's been subliminal advertising
that I didn't even real
recognize but or maybe it's just really
fitting for kind of the roads the you
know the line of our conversation I
don't know yeah what is our PG
role-playing game
Oh role-playing so this was like a
mechanic role-playing game horror this
is this is the old satanic panic Friday
July 24th 1981
experts warn occult games infecting
minds of children yeah then this is the
actual article I think it took place
this is writing about Chicago and the
fear well let's face it Chicago is still
killing a lot of people in fact I think
they're leading the way have been for a
long time so I'm not sure that they can
say it was just the RPG not a Bears fan
I take it
well definitely not anymore and is for
sure I should have poured you straight
vodka in there just a little floater
maybe you're right who do you cheer for
again yeah I mean then you know a really
good team mm-hmm so why why did you do
like what made you feel like a clothing
line was something that was a good idea
I'm in a street where yeah and I have
been I always keep up with with street
wear trends and like you know kicks and
you know a lot of some of the bigger
branded Japanese brands actually and
none of the Japanese brands make
clothing or shoes big enough for me yeah
we've covered that so so that was a big
impetus I wanted to I wanted clothes for
yourself I want a cool stuff that I go
where - but then aside from that a lot
of street wear generally skews either
Japanese or hip-hop okay and they were
borrowing from the well of heavy metal
and and really deep fantasy but it was I
saw it being done in a way that was not
pure I guess they were kind of slapping
skulls on things just because it was
cool but they didn't really know where
that skull came here or what the origin
of that design was or that's actually a
knockoff of this artist who painted this
painting in the 60s and then
you know or this album cover from the
80s and I know what they all are so as a
you know whatever a fantasy heavy-metal
historian I thought well somebody needs
to give yourself a new title business no
one's ever had that toy car I like it I
like it you know I thought well I could
do this right because I know III know
the progression and somebody needed to
go stick a flag in the ground and say
we're metal like this is metal this is
fantasy this is the real deal and if
you're a fan great and if you're not
we're still gonna make stuff so badass
that you're gonna want to wear it and so
you know right out of the gate I'd
launched at comic-con and good place for
it yeah people started lining up at five
in the morning why for a one o'clock
drop doors open of one were you there
signing and yeah I just said hey you
know doors open a wine everybody come on
out and people started lining up at 5:00
I got there and the lines were three
blocks long in San Diego which are huge
city blocks so it was three gigantic
city blocks oh my gosh
we sold it feels so good well yeah cuz
I'm like I said anybody gonna show up
because we're not in the convention
where I'm asking people to leave the
Commission come outside come to this
store line on a bootleg deal outside
comic-con all this was going on in there
I want you come on here and it was it
was like it was huge and people went
nuts we sold out right away we launched
online the next day all that sold out
within days Wow like Wow okay so so
we're on something there's a lot of
people out there who have been waiting
there's something like this when there
hadn't been yeah a lot of the artists
that I use I use I commissioned artists
from around the world in all kinds of
different places have different styles
different feels and we I match their
talents with you know a certain brand or
a certain character certain idea of
something that comes out of my head yeah
this are you the creative director for
the line I'm a creative director yeah
yeah I mean I did you ever see yourself
in that role ah no not like I never
thought I'd get in a street wear
clothing I think like you know being a
clothing designer that's a
little too daunting not really exactly
the perfect definition on the football
team I mean you're gonna get that title
oh yeah well I am now and I'm cool with
it but I mean I just think like back in
the day you know I wasn't funny you are
okay with being a Dungeons & Dragons guy
but not a clothing designer but on the
other side of you is sports that's right
so you know you said that when you were
a kid like you played Dungeons & Dragons
but then you kind of had this other side
of you two groups of friends the real
sort of like polar opposites of kind of
the you know prototypical kind of nerd
gaming kind of person to this jock
playing sports so was it could you
really keep them separate in school like
did you really have two separate groups
or was it just like you really I did
yeah well because you know if you're the
captain of the football team or the
cabin of the basketball team wall
there's a keg party you both and
volleyball teams oh yeah
you know there's a keg party on Friday
and the cheerleaders are there and the
girls are there you know so you're going
there oh yeah but then you know Saturday
you roll the world you have to wet them
all over Saturday or Sunday you might go
hang out with you know and and with a
game of friends so you know it was one
of those like guys I got to be done by
8:30 tonight there's a really big kegger
and you're not invited but I'll be gone
yeah I gotta go buy beer up at that
corner pub they think I'm 21 cuz I can
grow a little bit of a mustache which I
think sells it oh yeah no but that was
kind of it
so what age did that happen where you
were like man I I want both of these
lives on some level and they don't
really coexist from the beginning I
think it was always from the beginning I
always wanted both and people always
want to put you into one or the other
which I say these lives it's all yours
it's just acceptance really which is
something that's evolving so much right
now is acceptance like who gives who
gives a [ __ ] if you played on some
dragons but you can throw the football
as a freshman in high school you know 55
yards right yes well it just means that
I think that there's you know it just it
meant that I was a late bloomer because
where I think a lot of people have
one track or just that one life if you
want to call it that to develop I had
that one mm-hmm and then I had this one
I kind of had this other one over here
but I was kind of waiting in the wings
what well it's like you know I mean was
it the acting sure I mean that was the
thing is is I also made my own movies in
high school so that that was how I
backdoored in acting I would sleep with
a pad and a pen next to the bed and I
would just write dialogue for I would
cast all my friends I write that like we
go out on the weekends 6:00 a.m. we're
shooting we're chasing daylight I've got
a shot list and then you're like the OG
content maker for like vines before
there was anywhere to put it now it
started right cool cute funny crazy
little clips yeah so I had like shows
that were on the public access channel
the high schools public access town and
I'd you know I play in the game so that
my games would be on you know like high
school bat you know so it was like I
just was in I'm a handed a bunch of
things didn't you do surf yeah I'm not
good at surfing or skateboarding
it's cuts your cg center of gravity it's
a little too high I think yeah I just
it's bad you don't is the same thing
he's like you wanna know something I'm
not good at surfing I catch a wave and
I'm like like all that it took me all
that it took me to get that I'd rather
just sky down you're like my feet are
hanging off the back of the board it's
not big enough
yeah it's not not my thing so those were
kind of the try those are the tracks and
went and and at the end of high school I
was gonna go I should say like middle to
three-quarters of the way through I was
gonna play basketball to get into a
great school for academics and then I
was gonna go into criminal justice and I
was gonna go on a federal law
enforcement that was my that was my plan
I had a cousin in the FBI I'm starting
to figure it out I knew I could be
passionate about busting the bad guy
guys oh wait now you're gonna bust the
bad guy what's that's the thing that's
the Manganiello so it's a Manganiello we
were talking before it's a it's a billy
club Manganiello is a billy club that
cops beat people up with so obviously
like i come from a line of cops
justice somewhere in justice and then on
this side that was playing that was my
christian bit oh okay
he's in the Batman yeah I don't think
that man's a Nolan bad you would be so
disappointed with me I don't want that
stuff I haven't watched like any Lord of
the Rings like [ __ ] we watch a lot of
sports I like I mean it's things that
I've well I did watched your blood um I
really I like that so I like fantasy
like that I guess interesting um I don't
know I mean look I grew up watching nine
oh two one oh me too okay um now Rose
plays yeah I did yeah are you watching
the new 90210 I just saw some
advertisement for it last night and I
was like it put it is it called 9:02 I
know I think I don't know I'm interested
I mean it's worth um it's worth an hour
just to check out the new versions of
everybody and everything they're doing
see what they're up to but I I didn't
really watch a lot of stuff I mean I was
else like I might one of my favorite
movies growing up was was your boss yeah
great movie um or labyrinth love it
right did you see the Dark Crystal
no is that another well so labyrinth had
all the puppets with David Bowie yes
Dark Crystal was like a darker labyrinth
without any people cuz I watched
labyrinth now as an adult and I'm like
that scares the [ __ ] out of me
yeah they were your kids when they were
younger yeah and I love that and I miss
that about fantasy now I think fan yeah
well I think it's just the world there's
a part of the world that wants to go
like just see the movie demolition man
know whenever one they all sing theme
song of Taco Bell and they ride around
and it's very sanitized and then this
like criminal is unfrozen from like our
time in the future and he just like
takes over oh because they're just
they're so like just slays everybody
yeah they've just become so domesticated
that anyone with a bad intention could
like take over immediately so they have
to unfreeze Sylvester Stallone who's an
old cop who was kind of you know
hard-boiled like you know he'd beat the
you know beat the confession out of you
they needed him to go find this this
criminal anyway I think we're kind of
we're moving into that
a bit where we can't offend anybody it's
very easy trip you know they live in a
super duper PC world everybody needs to
toughen up a little bit I 100% agree
with you let's just suck it up buttercup
was that big of a deal stop being
offended the victim role is so prevalent
everyone's a victim
insane insane no I know I just I was
watching this documentary I mean I don't
I'll say but there was there's a
document I was watching recently about
you know talking about but but D&D and
they were talking about like people
saying like they were upset that they
weren't led into certain games growing
up his kids and it was like wool why
don't you just go by the book for 20
bucks or chop lift it or whatever he'd
get it online for free the PDF go dude
you'll get your own group of friends
what do you need these people for you
know it's a strange it's like you really
want to be the victim so bad it's like
yeah I didn't like a lot of the people I
was hanging out so you know what I
didn't hang out with them I want to hang
out with these people over here like you
just come on why do I want to whole just
one they just play that role and they
they lack imagination which you know
probably very much comes from lacking
you know like I'm sure you got a ton of
imagination from dungeons dragons right
make sure tons of creativity tons of
tons of tons of fantasy imagination but
they like that and they lack the the
drive and they're it's just so easy to
sit on your phone or so easy to complain
and then there's someone to soothe you
probably to support your shitty idea or
your perspective on yourself and yeah
you know instead it's like they're never
used to be that you just had to be bored
by yourself sitting at home looking at
the wall right you had to go find some
friends if you want something to do now
you can through your look on your phone
and find your friends based on all the
algorithms that they've produced to give
you all the information that you want to
see and feel good about yourself with on
social media or whatever platform you
use amen
mm-hmm started watching a show called
the great hack last night and I was like
oh god it's a documentary as well great
it's like learning about you know
basically how they use social social
platforms to create the algorithms to
get like you know four or five thousand
data points on every human being oh sure
I mean Google can do because that was
their thing they know everything puts
everything in front of you that
associated with those data points so
they are they're able to be listening
they have to I mean it's there this just
I thought this said was that there was
like one of the questions the very
beginning was raise your hand if you
feel like your phone's listening to you
based on the ads and everybody's like
yeah and he goes what is probably even
more true outside of that being possible
of course are happening is that the
algorithms are so good at projecting
what you're going to think or want or
talk about natural that it puts it there
because it's that good at it I woke up
the wrong way I had Preble with my neck
you know just woke up the wrong way you
know whatever when in see my guy who
does the thing I had an ad for an
Instagram they were advertising me the
neck pillows it's like how the what that
how would you oh I know because it's
tracking her into location it probably
knew you were at a chiropractic I shut
it off I don't let anybody try because
I'm worried I don't want I had problems
I just had to get my car check for
tracking devices because of where the
paparazzi were there's no way how did
you know I was going to pick up a
package at the UPS and whatever you know
Valencia how would you know that I think
it's a Sox it's crazy
so anyway hmm I shut it off okay alright
I don't know but that that's one of the
things but yeah yeah off the grid not at
all starting a convent I want to come do
you want to be off the grid we can play
Dungeons and Dragons no you can probably
really have dragons out there do you
believe dragons ever existed I mean not
unless there's fossilized proof do you
think that the medicine is there do you
leave with the row dinosaurs yeah I'm
not a flat earther
well I heard that they might not maybe
the bones weren't even put together
right
maybe dinosaurs are just sort of like
kind of made up I'm gonna lean into I'll
lead into probably myself but answers
true
yeah yeah there is some law for that
somebody made me dice recently as a
present that were made of like the head
like mammoth tusks in them yeah and
people went crazy online oh man how dare
you promoting the murder victim of
mammoths it's like I said I just posed
and years ago the dead they're gone
like it's a rock like you can't I'm not
telling people to go kill me do you
realize manis there they died out like
20,000 years ago yeah sure yeah yeah
some people don't even think earth was
around 20,000 years ago so there's also
that yeah
poor people still do a little warming
isn't real either mm-hmm well you know
Flat Earth is an interesting thing you
brought up I would say that it's
probably more likely I don't think it I
think it's round I do but I think it's
probably more likely than Flat Earth
that it's a holographic universe okay so
are we talking so we're like mentally
just like answer Donna hey we're kind of
filling stellar we're like our mind is
being populated by what we've learned
and experienced and just fills it all in
and it's everything in the world can be
broken down to zeros and ones what's
this what's this we are energy if you
condensed all if you content all humans
on earth down to actual matter
it's about size of an apple I ask Neil
deGrasse Tyson like the 21 grams type of
thing I don't know what's like when they
say when people die mm-hmm that's all
this is well no they say that they lose
21 grams of weight that's it this is
like a thing that they've measured they
say that the soul weighs 21 grams Oh
interesting
so there you go there's your so it's the
energy yeah that it goes somewhere so
the question is like are we all just
transmitting data back to a cloud is
there some kind of mothership and so far
off of this holographic universe idea
well there was there was a great cool
well like I think was a Playboy magazine
interview with with oh my god why am i
as watched my brains in there yeah so
Kubrick did this anyone and fascinating
guy in he he was talking about like the
greatest fear in life is that that you
know if there is a god it doesn't it
doesn't care that it's indifferent
everybody wants to believe that God's
sitting next to you and your convertible
on that sunny day driving in the PCH and
you know people want to
that it's not there when children are
dying in third-world countries
so there's this big argument as to you
know it's got everything or got nothing
and this guy got Karen so Kubrick had
this big huge he kind of like
brilliantly pontificated about this idea
that it doesn't care it's impartial and
that's the greatest fear so it's like
one chance it may have no purpose it
just doesn't it doesn't care like it's
just doesn't care it doesn't hear if you
like people are gonna get diseases
people are gonna die people thick random
shit's gonna happen and and it's just
it's all part of this so then where does
that put you in terms of you know it's
like Stephen Hawking Stephen Hawking his
entire life was a search for gone
basically and he died and said it
doesn't exist and that's I'm not sure
well you know like it was right or was
it just this is a guy who was stricken
with something so difficult and lived
the most difficult life out of anybody I
could ever possibly imagine
and maybe this was a personal thing that
like if this could happen to mean I had
to live like this the campaign I can't
be it can't be why would it do that
you're up religious like I was an altar
boy
I love till sixth grade yeah that go I
went to public school the next year and
I told my mom I said I have to dress
different cuz I'm going to public school
now yeah so you need to take me to the
mall and she did and I said I need a
Guns and Roses - I need a skid row you
really battled against the altar boy
outfit but I'll tell you this I are the
khakis and the best yeah first day of
seventh grade Skid Row shirt like the
hot girls are outside smoking cigarettes
the bad girls they smoke in seventh
grade oh yeah yeah they're cool smoking
cigarettes outside of high school I
walked by him on Skid Row ski shirt and
like the the hottest girl out of the
group was like nice shirt and I was like
would your parents think about that I
think your mom stuff yeah she was I mean
they didn't they just wanted you to be
happy
yeah but I think I think there was
definitely a seed planted from that that
connects to you know heavy metal street
wear cuz it's like you know there's
there's there's a group of people out
there who are pretty cool who like that
aesthetic and I want to take it back to
smoking outside the high school
and they're not ya want murderers not
fun I mean look you know I don't really
talk to a lot of those people today
because they gotten a lot of trouble as
adults but you know at the time it was
fun and I think there's a you know
there's a there's a youth there's a
vitality to that that kind of aesthetic
you know that that I remember so well
from the early and mid 80s like it was
fun you know
Danzig and Ozzy and Metallica like all
that stuff was fun and it had this like
fun energy to it and that's what you
know a lot of the line tries the capture
how does this bring you to a place where
you have this more spiritual awareness
now I mean to go from being a altar boy
dungeons and drag to Cesar's Satanist
obviously sorry wearing a shirt making
fun of satanic accusations there but how
does it how does that transition for you
like what what did you would you call
yourself spiritual now very much okay
what what does that mean to you to be
spiritual well you know I think I think
a lot of people live their lives and
don't get me wrong I think it works for
them I think David their lives afraid of
dying afraid of what's gonna happen
afterwards I think there are worse
things that can happen to someone I
think living in existence on this planet
that's I think he'll exists on earth you
know I think I have any good Cerner's
okay well how would you describe you
there of those I can explain it to
someone who's like you know the someone
would go heavens above and howls down
below right right I mean that's that's
what you're taught to just you read and
repeat I called them read and repeat
people well you know I visited a kid at
Pittsburgh Children's Hospital who was
on his 11th surgery in like two and a
half years or something and he had to
have his large intestine removed and he
had to drop out of high school and he
was put on an ostomy bag
he tried to go back to college and he
had another attack and had to go back
and then the medications are working and
he's like fighting for his life and just
the shell
I mean his skin color was like a
different color like it was a great
yellow okay
yeah and and it's he's broken and he
doesn't believe that he's gonna get out
of there he doesn't believe that he's
gonna be okay
and he doesn't believe that he's gonna
get back to a normal life or have
anything in life that resembles
something that you would strive for and
and you look at that kid and then you
look at his mom sitting next to the bed
and that's her kid
watching him do all of this and being
powerless to do anything about it
like that's hell faith is hell you're
stuck and so what keeps somebody going
through that you know what keeps
somebody who's paralyzed from the neck
down going who has to completely be
taken care of and all the all the help
that's being hired are doing a horrible
job and you know I know people like that
and I've talked to him and the only
thing that they can do or I guess that
the meaning of life is that maybe you
can help the next person you know that
that you have to be open or pray you
don't pray to be saved you pray to have
the strength to get through what you're
going through because you might be able
to be an example for somebody else you
know or provide hope but sometimes
that's the only thing that keeps these
people going you know it's you have to
pray to be open that maybe this
experience is turning you in a tougher
stronger smarter person it like Stephen
Hawking is a great example Stephen
Hawking was like a playboy who was like
running around drinking and having a
great old time and he was stricken with
this condition that he was told he's
gonna die very soon you know he wasn't
gonna make it long and it put him in
this wheelchair where all he had all day
long to do was think about the existence
of the universe and what started it and
if it wasn't for that condition he would
have been running around carousing and
doing his thing so it's a greatness yeah
so it's it's just about accepting your
situation and then so it's your
perception for your perception on the
situation
you know you can be sitting there and
obviously you can recognize the gravity
of a situation and the and the and how
terminal something might be and that's
hell or you can wreck or you can choose
to try and see it from a new light after
maybe digesting that and go maybe this
will save someone else's life and we
have this time and if it weren't for
this I wouldn't have we wouldn't have
this beautiful information from Stephen
Hawking we wouldn't and we wouldn't know
what we know we wouldn't have that
information that data that science that
perspective and that example of someone
that's pushing through something so you
know I don't know this is going I don't
know what what's you know where this is
gonna lead to but I'm just gonna try
moment by moment oh yeah the best I can
with what I've got to do you got a new
dog right how do you know this cuz your
heart out in an hour cuz you got a piece
of thing and let it get out is it under
six months no it's a rescue yeah it's
maybe all the time under six months but
after that it's years old you're good
that it's a it's a rescue and yes I mean
but that's a good example
you know this my wife was toying with
getting a new dog and saw this picture
of the super cute dog and had these
rescue bring it over for us to look at
and it just loved me it just loves me
wagon sure that you do didn't like dogs
or you don't I don't think you can say
you don't like dog now cuz you're in
love with this one my father was
allergic so we couldn't have him growing
out and it just wasn't you know and then
and then I was really allergic to golden
retrievers like if you walk me in a room
with a golden retriever I would probably
die within four hours so so we couldn't
have you know pets growing up so it just
wasn't on it and and I'm always I was
always so busy and traveling and running
around and getting here and getting
there and that I never it just I can't
do this but my wife her son had a dog
and she loved that dog so she was like
well what if we had our own dog and I'm
like
do you really want to do this and she
brought this little cute thing home and
it just ran right to me jumping up
wagging the tail flipping over and when
I submissive when it hears my voice it
just got hurt goes running wherever it
is this legs next to the door it jumps
up and I just picked this little thing
up and it just sits over my shoulder and
we walk around and we you know I sits on
my lap while I do my emails and do my
work and do writing medium-sized dog but
it just fits on your shoulders like that
yeah it's great yeah but what's heaven
like I mean I mean I love dogs so for me
like when I see my dogs when I seem when
I take my one of my most simple joyous
things that I do is taking my dogs out
for a walk whether I take them on the
beach whether I take them in the woods
and when they just take off and start
running after something and I can see
them kind of circling around and just
being so playful like the way dogs
should be I get mad at me they're not on
a leash I'm like you'll be on a leash in
in a box your whole life okay and see
how you would do like I want them to be
dogs and so when I see them get to do
that like I mean like it can bring me to
tears like to be like in that much of a
simple joy situation of being nature to
be with them and I just love it so I
love animals but what for you brings out
that like just such gratitude and like
simple simple that's one of them
definitely the other is like being in a
restaurant somewhere in Ravello or
Positano with with my wife you know like
you know you're gonna have the best meal
of your life you know you're sitting on
a little took a boat to get there you
can only take a boat to get to this
special restaurant now you're sitting
there and it's gonna be the best bread
you ever had the best Bharati I had the
best tomato you've ever had in your life
am i right the sensibility I'll give you
the whole Italy so oh my god it's it's
like they just they just have it figured
out you know they're crazy they're
passionate they're wild but like the
table is perfect and everything is
asymmetrical all the pleats don't match
all the glasses don't match but it's
like it's perfect it's like why would we
have it matches boy Italy consumes more
wine like per capita per person than any
other country combined or something like
which is just wonderful I make wine so
I'm just I should just go start selling
it there oh really that's a really
hardcore thing making wine like I'm a
big tulle fan oh yeah I'm a nerd makes
much better I've been in his place in
Jerome his cellar door in Jerome he gets
sources grapes from Napa and then also I
think he grows some in Arizona but he
has a cellar door as they would call it
in Jerome Arizona it's this like very
creepy spooky haunted town you prefer
dragons like could have like a revival
there but it's a role-playing central
but he yeah it's like this rewinding
windy road up to the top and it's this
haunted little tiny tiny town called
Jerome cool yeah if you know Maynard do
you know Maynard then huge yeah but I I
know that he I mean he was explaining
the process of like okay just make it
takes years make sure this grape grows
there and this way I bought my phone I
bought my property in 2009 and my first
bottle was for sale in 17 back to the
joy again sorry enough well you think
about so then you're very passionate
about yeah yeah but yeah I mean I think
you know yeah I mean like my my wedding
day you know it was a May it was amazing
seeing the Steelers went Super Bowl 43
in Tampa Florida but then also helped
seeing them lose Super Bowl for the
Packers and the Steelers played each
other did in Super Bowl 45 that's what
I'm saying I was there there's that six
turnovers we were gonna win with five
and then we had the sixth area shark
Mendenhall fumbled not that I'm that was
then that obviously was 2011 yep that's
right exactly I was there it was in
Dallas it was hell there was one person
I know that was really happy I know
actually I had a conversation with him
once about did you yeah you've met Aaron
yeah yeah we have crossed paths and we
talked about Super Bowl 45 mm mm how'd
that go not good for me yeah yeah yeah I
bet he made you feel like you were a
small little guard oh he was Darth Vader
very well he
um now it was very like subversive it's
very just like lots of this you know
like this thing was a good game that one
yeah for you guys we just did that
there's some there's something really to
me if I'm fascinating and I wish I knew
more about it but it kind of falls into
this joy spiritual spectrum which is
meditation don't you do I can never say
the word right but trance tenten
transcendence yeah transcendental
transcendental Transcendental Meditation
what is Transcendental Meditation
Transcendental Meditation is a
meditation technique that dates back
like 4000 years how long does it how
long is a meditation for you civil
session is uh it's like 20 minutes you
said if you get a mantra that's given to
you by a teacher who has studied with
the Maharishi in India
I'll come from India mantra means mind
vehicle oh wow that's great so and
you're not supposed to tell anybody your
mantra let's they give it to you is it
your own personal mantra for life or is
it just a is it a daily thing is it a
it's an automatic yeah which is a sound
like like pop or bang it's a sound so
you repeat the sound in your mind at a
certain volume level mm-hmm and then you
repeat it at a lower level then in the
lower level a lower lower and you just
as it you descend mm-hmm eventually the
mantra disappears and your mind takes
off and you start drifting ideally do
you feel like do you lose track of time
like as in you're almost like in a sleep
state like are you are you in what is it
Beta Alpha Theta like do you get into
theta brain wave state you can get some
you know some pretty trippy stuff
happening but somewhere between awake
and asleep when it's going now there's a
lot of mornings where you get up and
your brain is going oh no we got to do
this we got to do that on though I have
that notes call oh no I have this I have
that and you have to just take the
thought comes in and you have to just
take it back out return to the mantra
take it sometimes you're just fighting
yeah dan hey
from he's the he was the ABC got a
anchor that you know created the he has
like meditation books there's a Sam
Harris and there's Dan Harris but Dan is
the one that I'm talking about and he
explained meditation and kids like mmm
met a 10-minute meditation for fidgety
people or something like that he's a
couple of books but he said basically
like the point of it is is that your
mind just does what you said it just
thinks of something and then you clear
it and then it's all coming back it's
like the practice of meditation has a
lot to do with just bringing the mind
back back to neutral and away from the
distance away from the the thought
that's taking you from the simple
mindless but you learn to control your
mind and learn or strengthen your mind
it does work and what happens is then
you get you get more what's referred to
as adaptation energy so when the world's
going faster you have more on your plate
you can deal with that easier because
you can focus on tasks fully and then
move to the next so it's in practice of
being present I think probably you get
into that I knew somebody who I had
heard about it thought about it and then
someone gave me a call and said I guess
after having a conversation about
meditation somehow this random person
called me up and was like hey I'm going
to learn this this guy just came back he
lives in India but he's here do you want
to come I said sure so I went go is this
15 years ago oh wow something like that
and so I learned from this guy and then
years later and I and I meditated like
religiously like every morning and then
like somewhere in the afternoon 20
minutes twice a day every day for like
five years like I remember being on the
road driving to a Nine Inch Nails
concert in San Luis Obispo it was like
okay the concerts going to stand I
pulled over on the side of the freeway I
meditated my twenty minutes got back on
and then like went to a night of snail
show which is like kind of the officer
this is fascinating because I think
people would try and you know everybody
wants to put someone into a box and grin
identity for them and thinking you're
into this sort of more fantasy world of
you know
um aggression and killing kill the
goblins stuff like here you are well but
that matter the identity I think that
people have because I put it on
Instagram for the past year but they're
all that it would be like oh that's that
shirtless [ __ ] from Magic Mike you
know what I mean it's whatever you show
people is what you are to them right and
they don't that's who you are right but
it's instead of judging someone for one
thing that they see recognize that there
can be a lot more there so if you're an
actor it's kind of my job yeah - are you
acting right now so you don't do
meditation we're back to the meditation
I ran into David Lynch in New York and
he I knew he was a big meditator and he
had this transcendental meditation like
basically it's like a university kind of
here in LA and they try to bring
meditation to kids in school and also
communities because they've done all
these weird metaphysical like post Carl
Jung type of tests and they find that
that crime goes down and areas where
meditators right yeah interesting
yeah she goes back to the collective
collective consciousness so so I told
him I said oh I learned from this guy
who lived in India and did it I said who
I said the name he's a charlatan
changing all the Maharishi teachings we
have to you have to come learn from us
the next level purist here this guy so I
went and actually I just started dating
Sophia and um we just started dating and
I said hey I'm gonna go you know relearn
how to meditate at David Lynch's school
do you want to come on you you
interested you want to come with me you
can come with [ __ ] sure so we went great
today you mean somebody there near you
kind of like the money you like special
thing for me right off the bat with me
right off the bat
yeah yeah I'm some hippy weirdo you want
to come with you know so you're kind of
figuring out what their threshold is
sure your own weird that she was up for
it I totally and she went and we went
together and and I've kind of like
relearned I got a new mantra which is
pretty much like almost exactly the same
mantra though that's interesting do you
find that interesting I do
yeah maybe the other guy wasn't so
cookie then no maybe they're under
something but yeah it's changed a lot I
mean it's it's based on a frequency that
they feel of you I think it's like from
what I understand it's like it's a body
type and is a big factor body type and
age hmm are the factors that I hear go
into that but that's also weird because
there's almost a hundred mantras you're
sitting down with this complete stranger
and he closes his eyes and goes and he
gives a lot and you're like okay so this
guy knows the whole chart and every
there's a hundred body types like it's
very easy like yeah your eyes are closed
sir do you see that I am six foot five
strange yeah exactly
that's interesting it makes me feel like
it's based on your frequency like your
just your energy feel and sort of what
resonates like sort of a resonance
resonant frequency or sound because all
of our energy centers or chakras in our
body have like correlate with a note as
well so I've gone and got bought crystal
bowls like alchemy bowls and so when I
was searching when I was doing the
session because it's not just like go
pick one she's like very into it very
passionate so you sit down she pulls
bowls from you off the off the counters
and shelves all over the place based on
her intuition of you and then you sit
there and first you kind of get into a
little meditation with her and then you
sit there and she plays um and you
basically kind of do gladiator thumbs up
thumbs down or even say something but it
was like whoa I'd be like sometimes I'd
be like whoa like my hearts on fire like
you could feel it correlate with the
right shot and sure enough the note of
that bowl whether it be an F or a G or
an A would correlate with exactly where
I would feel it so I wonder if like the
frequency that you were putting on I
don't know we're going off on one here
no but I mean I find it I find it
interesting that that they both give you
the same note essentially or same sound
yeah it is strange but then there's also
the story of like the Beatles where they
went to India and they brought their
wives girlfriends whatever and they all
learn how to TM or Vedic meditate and
they were giving them
and they all got out and they were told
don't tell anyone your mantra and they
told each other and they all had the
same mantra and then they realized that
the guy that they met was a charlatan
who was just trying to sleep with their
girlfriends so there's that but you know
what it could be almost like a
spirituality or a belief or a religion
that if you believe it works it does
yeah I've seen some weird stuff in my
day yeah sure that's me yeah I mean
there's their stuff that's unexplainable
yeah you know yeah
like alien sightings right like did you
go in storm area 51 I would totally go
the idea was like if everyone shows up
they can't shoot us all somebody ain't
again in there I agree with that I'm
gonna confront shoot some of us I saw
something on Instagram was like screw
area 51 let's storm the Vatican and I
was like oh yeah good one go downstairs
into the into the Alexandra Library of
Alexandria yeah yeah get that stuff
I don't yeah I think there's yeah
there's a lot of things we don't know
how they build the pyramids alien your
think about that aliens but you don't
believe in aliens right uh well so I've
done I did an autograph signing in
England and the promoter also sets up
autograph signings for astronauts and so
he's met every single person who's been
in space except for like one so we have
been to the moon is that what you're
trying to tell me I'm saying we've been
there you think we're going to this guy
and every other astronaut so he told me
I said so you know he said for example
when he said that Yuri Greg Gering
wasn't the first man in space the first
man in space was a Russian that was sent
up and burn up on re-entry
they just burnt they were sent him up in
like I'm like it was like a wooden hot
tub like it'll burn up on the way back
and and so they didn't this they didn't
want to give in to this embarrassment so
they were like Yuri let's go you're
tough you know let's not talk about that
guys okay and so hot tub time machine
get him wet so yeah he gets in this
number
let's go so he he comes back and and
then they say oh yeah the first man in
space but there was a guy before that
and there are cover-ups and things like
that so he was getting in for you he
seemed like he was on the he's on the
up-and-up and so I said have you talked
to them about mmm-hmm the Dark Side of
the Moon
yeah and he said yes I have I said Wow
he said well there was one ship somebody
was out there on some space flight and
something whizzed past the window and
kept going and and they don't know what
it was and made no sense it moved in a
pattern that wasn't it wasn't like a
shooting stone that meteor or anything
it was some something changed direction
and and those one he said that all of
them unanimously believed in life on
other planets
they're like it's to infinite it's to
more has to be something else happening
I said well have they been to here and
he said all of them you mean animal II
say no they have not been or planet
mm-hmm that's not that's the inner ear
and our earth beings theory is out the
window for you to that makes sense to me
it's like you wouldn't if you came here
it would it would be a thing I don't
think you're it's the middle of the
night what are you doing you're floating
around and you don't think you could
hide it I don't think we went somewhere
else it'd be like we have the community
and we had I don't I just don't see that
I don't I don't know right so but also
it's not about what I think this is
about what yeah oh it is this interview
is all about what you think well this is
about science this no this is the
astronaut guy the guy who books is that
well in the other grass ice and thinks
there's aliens I would agree but have
they been like they've been here have
they been here
no no that's a good question I mean I
think that have you ever watched them so
there's a show I don't I don't watch a
lot at 4:00 a.m. and no it's not no it's
a it's on FX called Project Blue Book
no and it's about the last is the first
kind of car and obviously I need help I
only know that of my new race cars I
don't know how to buy old cars for the
road but this show is about it's about
basically taken from real experiences
real situations that happen in the
50s and 60s about alien sightings and
they've made a show about it so they'll
do an episode about a sighting and then
at the end of it they will show you what
the real and what the real stories were
back in 1959 or whatever it had whatever
it happened to support the show to
explain to you that that there was a
backstory to this episode and this is
what it is so it's cool anyway Project
Blue Book was a code for for all of that
stuff happening Blue Book was Project
Blue Book was the alien sightings
government code for it mmm the name so
it's an interesting show there's a movie
I can't think in the name of it because
I mean you know getting older but I will
look it up after it's it there was a
movie that came out I think was was at
Sundance last year where it was about
two kids in a little new New Mexico town
back in the 50s and yeah one of the kids
had a radio show and the other kid was
it was a girl she ran she was the
operator of the phone operator same time
anybody call and there was a power
outage and this weird sound came over
her operator
you know her headphones and the guy on
the radio show was interviewing somebody
and the sound came over his so they
picked up this weird signal and then
this mysterious guy calls into the radio
show and says I was listening to your
radio show and I heard that sound and I
heard it 20 years ago and I need to tell
somebody what happened and he talks
about having to clean up this crash it's
this really cool little tiny movie yeah
that has like long like 20 minute takes
whether you just kind of wander through
the town it was great and I need to
really cool very interesting so what
what what do you and so if you like to
do together I mean she doesn't play
Dungeons & Dragons I know that you you
know yeah we're both clothing designers
clearly I guess elaborate you don't
really talk about it I like it sound
weird okay she doesn't out your shirt
designs and sale a sometimes I'm sure
I'll show the artwork that's like we've
got
we're doing iron maiden right now and so
like the artworks like it's coming in
it's like amazing so I'll show her like
check this out we're gonna do this and
they died I'm gonna put it on this blank
and then we're gonna make it you know
she handle ear out of this design in the
air we're gonna hang them from the
ceiling on this thing and uh we watched
Netflix we go we travel Italy yeah go to
Italy we just went to Italy which is
awesome
so we have our spots that we like to go
there's some difference like kind of
like day trips around here that day
triple ike weekend trips yeah
everything's like two hours from yeah I
mean la is a cool place to be as far as
like getting to a mountain or getting
the beach getting to even go to Mexico I
mean I just wanna [ __ ] you were gonna
Julian no Julian's just little like it
looks like Deadwood like a little old
mining town up in the mountain I'm on
top of this mountain right very close to
San Diego and right around like now they
start getting these great Apple crops so
you walk through this Old West town and
every single place has their own type
apple pie means Apple boysenberry apple
strawberry apple then everyone has like
their homemade ice cream vanilla
cinnamon you know and you just hang out
walk around and eat apple pie that part
of your diet apple pie
sure sometimes eat really restrictive ly
I did I do when I have a project that
warrants that right middle Mike Magic
Mike five years of True Blood The Magic
Mike she said there were six years where
I trained twice a day six days a week
for ten months out of the year
ouch I guess a little you get yeah he's
just your trainer your trainer was
across that guy right he won the Masters
Comics 2016 masters yes the age
categories like 35 before he was the
fittest man over 45 in the world yeah
yeah so I go to CrossFit Games
empty oh man are you a mess and the last
three years I've been there
yeah I used to go in there in California
oh of course oh my god and I went to
actually go to California regionals and
then I go to the games in Carson every
year so um I mean it we what are we
doing we're opening a Pandora's box
right
I mean I probably should have led with
CrossFit cuz you only the how you know
how someone does CrossFit we led with
thousand dragons and now we're getting
across she's like I like the Ark you
know it's a different one I tried to
play only podcast ever where you're
going to get that transition that's
brought to you by talk about Helen have
a meditation your back weird okay kudos
thank you thank you you know I held it
in as long as I could but I had to ask I
was like I know you need to get going
and I know that you want to get back to
your dog with the dog's name bubbles
well of course this bubbles but how do I
not ask well this looks like a little
baby seal with a fox tail no it's just
this little thing and it's just like is
it a tear that actually just huge this
big it's this big it's a little baby
seal and then it comes running over to
me from across the floor and I and it
jumps up and and I pick it up and I just
sitting here and I just yeah I just walk
around it cute I bet that sure that's
cute just I can picture it now name is
bubbles okay we're gonna change it no
that's what the dog came with they were
like you're gonna change this I'm like
it's six years old I'm not gonna change
the thing's name don't change my name
use some street cred back though right
there by saying that it was bubbles
bubbles name has always been bubbles
plus it's like a friend of mine was like
listen man it's gonna be really hard to
be angry that's kind of yeah that's you
know you either got to name it like you
know something really tough and strong
or you go the other spectrum you just
call it like bubbles so I know you need
to get back to bubbles but we got to
talk about CrossFit for like three
minutes cool so you've been doing that
for how long
well um geez I the first year or two on
True Blood was probably which was like I
know what was that like Oh 10 like 10
2010 2011 that was like pretty much like
straight-up bodybuilding
and then the third year was when my
trainer Ron really got hardcore in
CrossFit left the private gym that we
were training at started his own gym
did you start the lab I ended up looking
him up because I was like who is this
guy yeah and because I read that he was
the fittest man I'm like I know the
fittest man it's been rich Froning I'm
at Frazier forever but but I was like oh
yeah he was a Masters champ so and
that's actually the gym that I would use
when last year at the beginning of the
year we stayed in that area and I went
to that CrossFit gym really yep did they
hook you up no central there I am NOT
the big dog while you're working out I
you know I need to lay on that floor and
I don't know what just happened here
before I got here anyway but you know
you could just pet the dogs all day over
about a GHD machine I get a workout yeah
exactly I don't want a GHD and getting
licked in my face unless it's bubbles so
do you feel like it was a big
transformation with your do you feel
like it was a transformative practice I
did it go from bodybuilding to CrossFit
I mean there's so much development in it
because there's lifting but it's just a
limping yeah there's not a lot of it
yeah that's right and I think I think
well I think the way that I worked out
at that point became it was like what
you would do with a football player so
it was like it was it was bodybuilding
and it was also like you know timed wads
okay you know and and AM wraps and
things so you're gonna yeah you're gonna
get your heart rate up while you working
out you're really gonna push hard but
you also do an Olympic you're working on
the big weights and then I would so but
it was like roll-to-roll
so goal on True Blood shredded with mass
okay got to get the morning cardio got
to eat then you get to go hit heavy
weights so that was the formula for a
while then it was I did sabotage where I
had read this book about a you know ATF
guy who infiltrated the Hells Angels he
was a college football player and I just
pictured my character so was playing
basically that character I was fixing my
thick neck big huge you know
scary-looking and so we did Olympic
powerlifting we did like all those high
poles on fleek we're like
yeah like heavy you know you know like
super heavy deadlifts heavy squats but
only like two wraps two reps and rest so
it's like lots of fun because you're
just you get the hang out so that's
around a lot go to the gym be huge
recover for like two and a half minutes
everything you can do two reps sit so
much fun
no but I got up I get put on like 30
pounds yeah got really big that was
great and then went back to True Blood
and then also I was writing a book about
bodybuilding and so I wanted those
pictures so at the time I was entering
you know period where it was like I was
gonna shoot all the pictures from my
book was you're gonna take like four or
four sessions like four days we
mentioned it out I was shooting men's
health UK men's health us and then
Muscle & Fitness
and those I hope you got them all in the
same week so you didn't have to be
miserable for too long like let's just
line it up that's how I agree I'm with
you but I need enough time in between a
recover from each shoot because you're
not gonna eat a big meal and then go
shoot you have to deplete and then like
I don't do water pills or drugs and you
know I was I was very I knew guys that
really messed themselves up doing that
stuff so I would you know stop drinking
water the night before to try to just to
hydrate mm-hmm
so that you could get the pictures right
mm-hmm so we we put like seven days of
shooting into two and a half weeks hmm
because I have a good night you a couple
days ridiculously shred about anything
crazy and it was ridiculous and but the
I remember on the last day of shooting
for the book the photographer was like
hey could we get you to climb that rope
and I was like I can't feel my I can't
look my arm stand here I'm so busy yeah
so I don't know what kind of permanent
damage all of that but the pictures are
great and someday you know be like hey
that's grandpa so respect grandpa you
see that
give me another and me some more garlic
bread yeah exactly as I crushed 30
plates of pasta in 12 days in English so
that was but that was um and so you know
coming out of that big powerlifting
chapter had a lot a lot of weight on and
so knowing that I was gonna do those
shoots yeah five six months and I knew a
cut just correct it just got so I was
massive yeah car it's the best yeah I
mean I actually worked ideal to mass and
then cut like that I've never been brave
enough to do a mass and cut I think I
accidentally a mass but I accidentally
mass but the cutting part is just zero
fun for me I'd rather like just stay
right at my minimums and then just still
work out because I hate being hungry
it's such a mental challenge it's
torture it's a real massacre you have to
have that type of personality because
you are like you know you are really
sticking it to yourself it is it is it
gets crazy so what's your favorite
favorite moves in CrossFit and then
least favorite and then I'm gonna let
you get back to bubble I like all the
overhead I like all the overheads I was
you know volleyball basketball hmm you
always had you know basketball you had
the ball you hold ball up over your head
you know volleyball you're always
playing with your hands up so there was
so much when I was younger of you know
you get to practice and it's like you
don't touch a ball for 20 20 30 minutes
you're just running and then blow the
whistle push up blow the whistle 10
jumps high as you can on the wall you
know whatever that all that stuff with
your arms above your head so you know I
know a lot of guys have trouble with
shoulder mobility
no problem so that's actually rich
Froning would say that like when I would
ask him because I'm I'm friends with him
and I said what you know what are the
things that you don't get beat he's like
overhead okay anything overhead
he's like tough to beat me on that no
overhead squats well balls those are
that a1 rowing I mean but they're going
of course you're 6 foot 5 imagine me
imagine me rowing well but those are the
few you're almost to the target for your
10 foot target now you got me down here
at the nine-foot target it's not fair I
would you thirty pounds we 14 for those
who don't know it's 24 guys and 14 for
girls I have done one
pound med ball wall balls just like I've
done Karen for just like which is 150
wall balls but I would use the try use
once you are happier if you train a
heavier when you get into a workout or
competition like it's if you train
heavier than what the the rx is you're
gonna be fine
that's pretty much I mean like that's if
there's anything that I've seen with
CrossFitters and seeing rich and seeing
them train and having been to mayhem and
you know going to the game like I mean
I've seen he's stayed in the house
before so they they have to train with
giant volume so that the games are
totally digestible so it's like for five
days and that I mean that's that's
brutal Mike so my trainer Ron he you
still go
does he still do mastered no no he's
taking a break he's he's 6-2 and
competed at 240 and 245 like in that
ballpark so six to 240 he's the tallest
by four inches at least and probably the
heaviest by yeah I mean we're time and
when you look at almost 50 pounds we may
look at Tia who's the female like last
three years games champ for individuals
she's like five four oh one thirtieth
yeah exactly so let me feel pretty bad
about myself
actually I'm like she cleaned 265 ok
well that's the crazy thing is like Ron
they did he beats the smaller guys in
the gymnastic movements he would crush
them in muscle ups he would crush them
and pull up that's it he's gonna go down
he's done like pull-ups there yeah once
he gets to the weights he'll be ok but
the pull-ups he'll get correct he beat
them all on the pull-ups got off got to
the weights it was big axial bar oh he
was he had to clean with the axle on and
just crushed everybody so then your
least favorite would be burpees run
burpees Burpee is the enemy of anything
over six foot it's I love it they're not
dynamic there's it's like what am i
dropping it's like oh it's like I'm in
the grass and I know in like a army
movie it's like this is terrible it's
like rounds a football practice and the
grass and the heat and like I guess it's
like why am i you probably nobody
cares how many how fast I do this I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you what I did one
time because I was didn't want to think
of multiple movements and I was like hmm
I'll do a thousand burpees for time I
ended up deciding that I shouldn't
because I didn't have enough time for
that and it was gonna take over an hour
you do have this masochistic I did 500
for time okay where was your time I was
about 35 minutes I camera 30 about 25 or
35 something I only stopped her right
down the hundred every hundred I wrote
the time on the clock and then I did
another hundred and then I wrote the
time on the clock so no so then you know
we'll just meet back up at the lab and
just have a workout that has burpees and
wall balls and row it burpees and rowing
or burpees and wall balls which one do
you want
I'll go Baba I would be some wall balls
and we'll just see where it pans out
sounds like that sounds like hell on
earth there it is that's my answer
what's hell on earth but you know it is
ever be can be heaven winning all right
thank you so much okay we're gonna
overhead squat okay so good I like over
it yeah thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today I
hope you enjoyed it and also thank you
so much Trevor Hall for the awesome
music if you like what you heard today
and you want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button
[Music]